.
>> MEANTIME, RUSSIA CLAIMS TO BE
HOLDING THE LINE IN MOST AREAS.
>>> RIGHT NOW NATO'S BIGGEST
EVER DEFENSE EXERCISE IS
UNDERWAY IN GERMANY.
THE DRILLS INCLUDE 10,000
PERSONNEL REPRESENTING 25
NATIONS.
OFFICIALS WITH THE ALLIANCE SAY
THIS SENDS, QUOTE, CLEAR MESSAGE
THAT NATO IS READY TO DEFEND
EVERY INCH OF ALLIED TERRITORY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WILL ALSO, BY
THE WAY, HOST NATO SECRETARY
SOEL
JEN
SOLTANBERG AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE WILL GET TO THE DRILLS IN A
MOMENT.
IF WE COULD BEGIN WITH THE
SITUATION IN UKRAINE AS WE
SPEAK, PRESIDENT VOLODYMR
ZELENSKYY'S CHIEF DIPLOMATIC
ADVISOR TOLD CNN YESTERDAY THAT
THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF THE
COUNTEROFFENSIVE CAMPAIGN IS TO
WIN BACK ALL OF THE TERRITORIES,
INCLUDING CRIMEA.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT IT'S
FEASIBLE?
>> WELL, UKRAINE DEFENDS THEIR
OWN TERRITORY AND THE RIGHT OF
SELF-DEFENSE IS ENSHRINED IN THE
CHARTER AND THEY ARE TRYING TO
LIBERATE THEIR OWN LAND.
BUT WE HELP THEM WITH UPHOLDING
THE RIGHT OF SELF-DEFENSE.
AND I THINK THAT THIS OFFENSIVE,
WHICH IS DIFFICULT, IT'S STILL
EARLY DAYS.
BUT, OF COURSE, THE MORE LAND
THEY GAIN, THE MORE LIKELY THAT
PRESIDENT PUTIN WILL UNDERSTAND
THAT HE HAS TO SIT DOWN AT THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE AND AGREE TO
PEACE IN UKRAINE.
>> THERE IS PLENTY ON YOUR
AGENDA WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN
TODAY.
I THINK ONE OF THE MOST PRESSING
ITEMS IS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO WILL TAKE YOUR POTENTIAL
WHEN YOU DEPART.
YOU HAVE BEEN EXTENDED.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THAT
DECISION WILL BE MADE AND IT'S A
COLLECTIVE DECISION, SOMETIME IN
THE VERY NEAR FUTURE?
>> I HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
MOST ALL DECISIONS IN NATO
EXCEPT FOR ONE, AND THAT IS HOW
TO SELECT MY SUCCESSOR.
MY FAIN FOCUS -- THAT'S 31
ALLIES TO DECIDE.
I AM CONFIDENT THAT THEY WILL
FIND AN EXCELLENT SUCCESSOR.
MY FOCUS NOW IS TO LEAD THIS
ALLIANCE TO THE END BECAUSE WE
ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF WAR IN
EUROPE AND WE NEED TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE AND NEED TO ALSO ENSURE
THAT WAR DOESN'T ESCALATE BEYOND
UKRAINE AND BECOME A
FULL-FLEDGED WAR IN EUROPE.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO HAVE -- THE
EASTERN PART.
>> WE MENTIONED BEFORE BRINGING
YOU IN THESE REALLY HUGE DRILLS
AND NATO EXERCISES GOING ON
TODAY, NOTABLY SWEDEN IS
INVOLVED IN THOSE.
SWEDEN 'ASCENSION TO NATO HAS
BEEN BLOCKED ABOUT I TURKEY BUT
I HAVE CONSISTENTLY SAID THAT
YOU BELIEVE THAT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY MADE IN THEIR
LAWS TO ASSUAGE THE CONCERNS OF
TURKEY WILL MEAN THAT THEY WILL
BE ADMITTED.
HAVE YOU HAD ANY INDICATION FROM
PRESIDENT ERDOGAN THAT HIS
POSTURE HAS CHANGED ON SWEDEN?
>> I AM CONFIDENT THAT SWEDEN
WILL BECOME A FULL MEMBER.
ALLIANCE AND THEY HAVE COME A
LONG WAY.
ALL ALLIES ALSO PRESIDENT
ERDOGAN DECIDED TO INVITE SWEDEN
TO BECOME A MEMBER AND BY GIVING
THEM WHAT WE CALL THE INVITEE
STATUS, SWEDEN IS NOW SITTING AT
THE NATO TABLE INTEGRATING MORE
AND MORE INTO NATO MILITARY AND
CIVILIAN STRUCTURES.
WHAT REMAINS IS THE LOST BIT,
THE FORMAL RATIFICATION BY ALL
ALLIES OF SWEDEN.
I MET WITH ERDOGAN A FEW DAYS
AGO.
WE AGREED TO CONRINA MECHANISM.
THEY ARE MEETING THIS WEEK IN
ANKARA TO ADDRESS THE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES AND DO WHAT
WE CAN TO HAVE SWEDEN AS A FULL
MEMBER AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> IS IT YOUR VIEW THAT TURKEY
IS WHAT NEEDS TO GIVE HERE OR
THE TURKISH GOVERNMENT NOT
SWEDEN.
SWEDEN DOESN'T NEED TO DO
ANYTHING MORE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT PRESIDENT
ERDOGAN AND HIS TEAM NEED TO
SHIFT ON?
>> MY MESSAGE HAS BEEN FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS ALSO IN ANKARA
THAT SWEDEN HAS DELIVERED ON
THEIR COMMITMENTS THEY MADE AT
THE NATO SUMMIT LAST YEAR IN
MADRID.
THEY HAVE LIFTED ALL THE
RESTRICTIONS ON ARMS EXPORTS TO
TURKEY AND THEY HAVE STEPPED UP
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH TURKEY --
TERRORISM AND AMENDED THE
CONSTITUTION.
CONSTITUTION ALSO STRENGTH
ENCOUNTER TERRORIST LAWS.
OF COURSE, WE WELCOME THAT WE
SEE MORE ACTIVITIES BASED ON
THIS CHANGES.
SO THIS WEEK A NEW DECISION TO
EXPEDITE A PERSON CONNECTED TO
PKK AND THAT PROVES THAT SWEDEN